[拍手]
皆さんこんにちは
私は大学で
性の多様性について教えています
正の多様性についてどう思うかと学生に
尋ねると
学生からは
誰を好きになるのもどの性別で生きるのも
個人の自由だから良いのではないかという
反応が
返ってきます
しかし私は一人の同性愛者としてこのよう
な反応というのは
正の多様性を
他人事として
捉えているのではないかと感じています
実際に
授業の中で
同棲を好きになるのは
個人の自由だから良いと思う」と尋ねると
学生の大半が賛成をします
しかし
家族から同性愛者だとカミングアウトされ
たら
個人の自由だから良いと思うかと尋ねると
賛成する割合は大きく減ります
このことから
わかるのは
個人の自由だから良いというのは
実はその個人が
自分とは関係のない個人を想定しているの
ではないかということです
それでは
正の多様性を
他人事として捉えることがどのような問題
をもたらすのか
一橋大学で起こった出来事から
説明してみたいと思います
2015年
8月
一橋大学の大学院生が
同級生から
同性愛者であることを
暴露されて
大学の校舎から
転落死をするという出来事が
起きました
その出来事の4ヶ月前です
その大学院生は
同級生から
同級生に対して
恋愛感情を告白していますここからは
恋愛感情告白した大学院生を
Aさんそして
告白された大学院生をBさんと呼びたいと
思います
Bさんは
aさんに対して
付き合うことはできないけれども
これからも良い友達でいてほしい
世の中には一定数同性のことを好きになる
人もいるから
自分を責めなくてもいいと答えました
このことからわかるのは
Bさんは
同性愛について一定の知識を持っていたと
いうことです
その後
Bさんは
aさんに対して
断ったにもかかわらず
Aさんが以前と同じように食事や遊びに
誘ってくることが理解できずに
次第に精神的に不安定になっていきました
そして
Aさんも参加している
グループLINEにこのような書き込みを
しました
俺お前がゲイであること隠しておくの無理
だ
ごめん
Aさんは大学で同性愛者であることを
オープンにしていませんでしたこの
書き込みによって
同級生の大学院生に
自分が同性愛者であることを
知られることになりました
その後
Aさんは
心身ともに調子を崩し大学の授業にも出
られなくなりそして
大学の校舎から
転落死をすることになりました
同性愛について知識があったはずの
Bさんがどうしてアウティングをして
しまったのでしょうか
ちなみにアウティングというのは
他人に知られたくないと思っている
セクシャリティに関わる事柄を
本人の同意なく
暴露することです
Bさんは
同性愛者が今の社会の中でどのような
差別や偏見に
囲まれているのかそしてその差別や偏見が
自分とどういう関係にあるのか
考えたことがなかったのではないでしょう
か
そのため
もし自分が
同性愛者であるということを
暴露したら
Aさんがどういう恐怖を感じることになる
のか
想像できなかったのではないかと思います
正の多様性を
他人事として捉えることそれが
一人の命を奪うということにつながるそう
いうことをこの一橋大学の事件は
示していると私は思います
それでは
正の多様性を
自分のこととして捉えるには何が必要
でしょうか
私は
自分の持っている
特権について
自覚をすることが大切であると考えてい
ます
皆さんは
特権と聞いて何を思い浮かべますか
財産や
政治権力を持つ一部の人のことを
思い浮かべる人も多いのではないかなと
思います
しかし
特権というのは一部の人のみが
享受しているものではありません
ここで
特権についての
新しい定義を
紹介したいと思いますその
定義というのは
社会的に有利な立場であることによって
得られる
恩恵というものです
この定義に従えば
社会における多数派であるマジョリティも
また
特権を持っているということになります
なぜマジョリティが特権を持っているかと
いえば
数が多いことによって
社会的に有利な立場にいるからです
しかしながら
多くのマジョリティは
自分が
特権を持っているという
認識を持っていません
なぜかといえば
多数派である特権というのは
努力や苦労して
得たものではないからです
それでは
多数派であることによって
得られる恩恵というのはどのようなもの
でしょうか
ここでは
性における
多数派である
性的マジョリティと
性における
少数派である性的マイノリティが
どのような基準で区別されるか2つ紹介し
たいと思います
1つ目の基準は
スライドにもあるような
性的指向です
異性に惹かれる
異性愛者が
多数派で
同性に引かれる
ゲイやレズビアン同性愛者が少数派に性的
志向ではなります
性的嗜好によって
異性愛者は
多数派になりますけれども
異性愛者であるということによって
異性愛者は
自分のパートナーについて
オープンに語れるまた
自分たちの関係について
周囲から
祝福される
病院で
家族として扱われるこういうことは
異性愛者にとって
当たり前のことではないでしょうか
しかし
同性愛者にとっては
決してこれらのことは
当たり前のことではありません
2つ目の基準は
自分の性別をどのように認識するかを意味
する
政治人です
政治人と
生まれた時に割り当てられた性別が一致し
ているのが
シスジェンダーで
生まれた時に割り当てられた性別と
政治人が異なるのが
トランスジェンダーです
シスジェンダーにとっては
トイレや更衣室を
気兼ねなく使える
外出するときに
周囲の目を気にしないで済む
自分の望んだ性別で
治療を受けることができるこういったこと
は
当たり前のことではないでしょうか
しかしトランスジェンダーにとっては
決して当たり前のことではありませんこれ
らのことを
当たり前にできるのは
シスジェンダーが
特権を持っているからです
それでは
特権を自覚することが大切かなぜ大切なの
か2つ理由を
示したいと思います
1つ目の理由は
多数派の持っている特権というのは
少数派の犠牲の上に成り立っているという
ことです
ここにいる皆さんの中には
家族やカップルで部屋を借りて
生活をしているという人も多いのではない
かなと思います
しかし
同性カップルにとっては
部屋を借りて
生活をするということは
容易なことではありません
なぜかといえば
同性カップルに偏見を持っている大家や不
動産屋が存在しているからです
実際に私も
同性のパートナーと
住む
部屋を探すために
不動産を何件も何件も回ってようやく住む
家を探すことができたという経験を持って
いますこのことからわかるのは
家族やカップルで
部屋を借りることができるというのは
特権であるということです
そして
異性のカップルは
同性カップルが拒絶された部屋の中から
自分たちの
住む部屋を
選ぶこともできます
このことが意味しているのは
多数派であることによる特権というのは
少数派の犠牲の上に
成り立っているということです
特権を自覚することがなぜ大切か2つ目の
理由を
述べたいと思います
その
理由は
自らの特権を自覚していないことによって
知らないうちにマイノリティを傷つけて
しまうことがあるということです
皆さんは
会話をしている相手が
異性に引かれているということを前提に
彼氏いる
彼女いると尋ねたことはないでしょうか
また
男性の外見だと思ったら
君
女性の外見に見えたら3をつけて読んだ
ことはないでしょうかまた
私そっち系じゃないからという冗談を言っ
たことはないでしょうか
これらの言葉というのは
あからさまに性的マイノリティを傷つけて
いるわけではありません
しかし
性的マイノリティが自分の周りには存在し
ていないということを前提にして
語られています
このような
性的マイノリティを傷つけるような
言動のことをマイクロアグレーションと
言います
マイクロアグレッションのマイクロという
のは
ちょっとしたという意味ですけれども
ちょっとした言葉や行動によって
特定の集団を
軽視したり
侮辱したりするような言動がマイクロ
アグレーションです
マイクロアグレッションというのは
些細な言動ですけれどもそれが
生涯にわたって
積み重なることによって
性的マイノリティの
心身に
深刻な影響を及ぼします
それではマイクロアグレッションと特権と
はどのような関係にあるのでしょうか
彼氏いる
彼女いるという問いかけは
質問している相手が
自分の好きな人について
オープンに話すことができるという前提が
ありますしかし
好きな人のことを
オープンに語れるというのは
特権です
ということは
特権を自覚していないことによって
マイクロアグレーションを行ってしまって
いると言えないでしょうか
最後に
自分の特権を
自覚して行動することが
社会を変えることにつながるということに
ついて
話したいと思います
皆さんは
洗いという言葉を
聞いたことがあるでしょうか
荒いというのは
多数派の中に
所属していながらも
差別を是正するために行動する人のことを
荒いと呼びます
この言葉は
同名者を意味する
英語のアライアンスに由来しています
それでは
新井として行動することがどうして大切な
のか
沈黙の螺旋を使って
説明したいと思います
沈黙の螺旋というのは
東由紀さんが
研究した成果に基づいています
スライドの1番をご覧くださいこれは
性的マイノリティの
周りで
差別的な言動が
起こったことを意味しています
差別的な言動に遭遇した時に
性的マイノリティは
多くの場合
沈黙を選びます
そのことによってその場にいた人たちは
差別的な言動に対して
誰も何も反動しないので
自分の周りには性的マイノリティはいない
だろうという認識を
以前よりも
強く持つようになります
そのことによってその場におけるあるいは
その集団における
差別的な価値観っていうのは一層
強化されます
これらの積み重ねによって
性的マイノリティは一層沈黙を強いられる
ようになりますこのような
沈黙そして
差別的な価値観っていうのが
螺旋のように
強化されるこれが
沈黙の螺旋の意味するものです
それでは
沈黙のラセンを止めるためには
何が必要でしょうか
まず
性的マイノリティが
沈黙村線を
止めるということは
容易ではありませんなぜかと言ったら
差別的な言動が行われているときに
そういうことを言うのやめようよともし
性的マイノリティが言ったらどうして
そんなことを言うのもしかしてそうなのと
いう反応が
返ってくることを
性的マイノリティは
恐れるからです
しかし
性的マジョリティは
性的マイノリティよりもそういうことを
言うのやめようよという一言を
言いやすい立場にいますなぜかと言ったら
マイノリティではないことによって
より中立的な立場で
発言をしているのではないかと
受け取られるからです
ここで
注目してほしいのは
マジョリティが
発言した一言というのはマジョリティの
特権に基づいて
行われているということです
マジョリティは
沈黙のラセンを止めるために
特権を行使しています
自らの特権を自覚して
行動することによって
性的マイノリティが
生きにくい社会を変えることができます
皆さんは
正の多様性というと
性的の性的マイノリティの問題であると
いう考え方に
触れたことがあると思います
しかしマイノリティが
経験している
生きづらさや困難というのは
多くの場合
知識がなかったり
偏見を持っているマジョリティによって
もたらされます
性的マイノリティが行きやすい社会が作ら
れるためにはマジョリティが
変わっていく必要があります
それでは
マジョリティが行動する原動力っていうの
は
マイノリティの生きづらさを変えていくと
いうことに
尽きるんでしょうか
私はそうは思っていません
皆さんは
自分が特権を持っているということに
気づいた時知った時に
居心地の悪さを感じなかったでしょうか
もし
居心地の悪さを感じたとしたらそれは
多数派が
享受しているものというのは
すべての人が
享受すべきであると
感じたからではないでしょうか
マイノリティが
生きづらい社会というのはマジョリティが
自らの特権を自覚した上で
変えていくことができます
自らの特権を
自覚した上で行動するこれが
社会を変えていく
鍵になると私は考えています
ご清聴ありがとうございました
[拍手]